hey guys this is vadim with max tech and
right here in front of me
i have the long awaited galaxy tab s7
you guys have been waiting for this
video for a while i have the 2020 ipad
pro and we're gonna be comparing
these two with basically everything the
displays
the 120 hertz the keyboards
everything you can imagine we're going
to be comparing in this video and as you
can see i have the magic keyboard case
right here
and we actually did grab the book cover
keyboard for the tab s7 but
i'm going to set this aside because
we're going to be comparing that later
on in this video
so without further ado let's do our
signature unboxing
all right there we go and i've got to
say this actually looks quite a bit
different
compared to last year's tab six
especially this here there used to be
like a little groove
on the back of the tab s6 but now it's
flat
with this nice little i don't know if
it's a glass or plastic piece
for that s pen which actually comes
included so that's really nice
so let's go ahead and compare the design
between these two but first of all i
want to talk about the chargers
the tab s7 comes with the 15 watt
charger which is interestingly
usb-a compared to the ipad pro comes
with a usb-c
charger and it's 18 watts so 18 for the
ipad pro versus 15 so
the ipad is going to be charging faster
but the tab seven does support 45 watt
fast charging but you have to buy that
separately
and as far as the battery sizes that are
built into these tablets themselves
we have 7600 for the ipad pro and
8 000 for the samsung so it's just a
little bit more
now let's go ahead and get into the
design differences between these two
now first of all before i start
comparing them i do want to mention the
weight difference
the ipad pro weighs 1.04 pounds compared
to
1.1 pounds for the tab s7
now i'm going to take this s pen i'm
going to put it aside we're going to be
comparing the
latency and different things a little
bit later in this video
but for now i do want to look at this
new design
for the tab s7 which i mean obviously
it's just like the ipad pro the main
difference i'm seeing is that these
sides are now kind of glossy they're
brushed like a brushed metal look
compared to
pretty matte for the ipad pro which
wraps all the way around to the back now
i want to give props to samsung for
copying apple's design because this
really does
feel more modern more premium i really
like this metal feel
and it's much better than the old tab
s6's
chamfered edges now as far as the camera
bumps i've got to say that i do like the
one on the ipad pro better just looks
better overall with the design of the
ipad pro but this does go in line with
that charger so it's not that bad
we have a wide camera on both and ultra
wide along with the flash
but the ipad pro does have the lidar
scanner
which we're gonna get into later on in
this video now on the ipad pro the apple
pencil charger is actually right here
on the side it charges wirelessly so it
just
magnetically connects just like that and
finishing off with the exterior
differences we have quad speakers
on the top and bottom on each of these
they both have
usb type c and the samsung has its
kind of smart connector right here on
the side compared to
on the back for the ipad pro now i flip
them over to the front and one thing i'm
immediately noticing
is that the ipad pro is actually a
little bit thinner just just looking
from the side
the tab s7 is definitely sticking out so
it's a little bit thicker than the ipad
pro
getting into the displays themselves i'm
seeing some differences right away but
before we do that
let's compare face id on the ipad pro
compared to
fingerprint recognition on the tab s7 so
the most interesting thing is that we're
getting the sensor
on the side this time instead of in
display like we had on the tab
s6 let's start scanning right here on
the side
and i guess it makes it more difficult
because it's like a thin
power button so you kind of have to put
your finger everywhere to
get a full scan so now it wants me to go
kind of all the way around so let's
first test out how face id works on the
ipad pro
you can simply tap and just swipe
to open it happens instantly and what i
really like is that you can even turn it
upside down and it works upside down too
or sideways so i really like that you
have face id
on the ipad pro now let's test out the
tab
s7
look at that oh that's beautiful wow
yeah that's really quick let me try a
different finger
my thumb instantly wow
so based on this i'm definitely saying
that the tab s7 is
faster to log in because you just have a
simple touch like that but the downside
is that
if you want to just tap the display and
get going you can't really do that on
the tab
you still have to put your finger up
there to unlock whereas with face id
you just tap the screen and it scans
your face and you're good to go
now back to the displays the first thing
that sticks out to me is the aspect
ratio difference
16 by 10 for the samsung and the ipad
pro has a little bit of a weird
aspect ratio but you guys will see it on
your screen now these are both
the 11 inch display models the tab
actually has a 12.4 inch model that's
the plus size
and the ipad pro has 12.9 so between
these two
you definitely see that both of them
have rounded corners so that looks
really nice and modern but one
difference i'm instantly noticing is
that the bezels
on the ipad have deeper blacks it seems
like the display on the tab
is more reflective so let's go ahead and
test out the reflectivity i can
definitely notice that the tab
is more reflective than the ipad pro
as far as the display quality itself the
samsung does have more resolution
i believe it has 274 pixels per inch
compared to 265 for the ipad pro
and with that let's get into the
brightness comparison of the display
so you guys are seeing the brightness
difference from the above camera
so the ipad pro should be looking a
little bit brighter but let's go ahead
and test
the off access shift let me know which
one
does a better job at brightness shift
the last display difference i want to
mention is the display quality in terms
of the technology
now the tab s7 this year it actually
ditches
the amoled display that it has had for
years so it has
a lcd display just like the ipad pro
but the benefit is is that we can still
choose hdr
within youtube we could actually go up
to 1440p
compared to only 1080p on the ipad pro
all right even though the samsung has
1440p and it has hdr enabled
it actually looks like the ipad pro
looks better in general in terms of
the colors in terms of the brightness
just everything looks like
a better image overall max also took a
peek and he actually thought that the
ipad was the samsung at first because he
expected it to look better
and then he realized that they were
switched so it's very surprising that
the ipad pro
is beating out the samsung even though
it doesn't get those better settings
so there are three reasons for that the
first one is that the ipad pro is
brighter
the second is that the display tech
could actually be better on the ipad
pro and it looks better overall even
though it's less resolution for that
video
and the third reason is that the display
coatings on the ipad pro are better so
there's less reflectivity
compared to the more reflective samsung
display that looks
more gray compared to the deep black of
the ipad pro
now the reason samsung ditched the
amoled display was
for the 120 hertz technology as you guys
can see right here
i have adaptive mode on which allows it
to transition between 120hz
and 60hz but the ipad pro has had
promotion technology for a very long
time
it stays at 120hz almost all the time
but when you're watching something like
a youtube video like our youtube videos
which are filmed at 24 hertz or 24 fps
the display goes down to 24 hertz and it
matches it so it saves
battery life so we just set our top
camera to record
at 120 fps so you should be seeing a
slow motion comparison between
both of these tablets at 120 fps or 120
hertz
let me know which one looks better or
more smooth and based on what i'm seeing
the samsung looks really smooth
finally they've added 120 hertz now
another benefit to having a display that
runs at 120 hertz is that the pencils
the s pen and the apple pencil
they have less latency so on the ipad
pro it's recently went down
to nine milliseconds and same with the
samsung it's also 90 milliseconds so
let me know which one looks better in
this slow motion comparison
and with that let's finally get into our
speaker comparison
these both have quad speakers so make
sure you put on your best set of
headphones or earphones
to listen to the quality
[Music]
so let me know what you guys think down
in the comment section below
to myself personally i think that the
samsung was a little bit louder
with louder highs but i think the mids
and the bass were pretty similar on both
with that said let's go ahead and get
into the camera comparison
so the front facing cams on both of
these we have 7 megapixels on the ipad
pro and we have eight
for the tab s7 and one thing that's very
interesting is that the tab has
its camera right here on the side and
that's because it's meant for using it
with a keyboard case which we're gonna
put on in just a minute here
but the ipad pro has it on the top so
let me know which one of these selfies
looks better to you now while the
samsung doesn't have the same truedepth
face id sensors as the ipad pro
you still get live focus selfies which
is nice now as far as the cameras on the
back
the ipad pro has a 12 megapixel wide
camera compared to
13 megapixels on the samsung tab s7
but for the ultra wide the samsung only
gets a 5 megapixel ultrawide lens
compared to 8 for the ipad pro so let me
know which set of images looks better
down in the comment section below
as far as video recording the ipad pro
is definitely the best choice because it
can shoot
4k 60 with either the ultrawide or the
wide lens
and the samsung can only shoot 4k 30
with either of them and of course the
ipad pro also gets the added
lidar scanner which can be used for
augmented reality apps
and apple should be revealing more
features with lidar
at next month's event so now let's
finally jump into the performance
comparison
now both of these models have six
gigabytes of ram
but with the samsung you can actually
get eight if you upgrade the storage
the ipad pro comes with the a12 z chip
compared to the snapdragon
865 plus on the samsung galaxy tab
s7 so let's go ahead and run the cpu
benchmark
all right so we got our scores back and
wow this is insane so
the ipad pro actually has 15 more
single core performance compared to the
tab s7
but in the multi-core we're getting over
50 percent more performance and with
that let's go ahead and test the
graphics using
gfx bench we've got metal on the ipad
pro and we have actually
opengl and vulkan these two tests on the
samsung so let's get started
alright so we have our results back and
wow this is impressive
the ipad pro is getting 57 fps compared
to 22
and 23 on the tab s7 so we're definitely
getting
a lot more graphics power this would be
very interesting to see
in terms of gaming like 120 fps games
so if you want to see a video like that
definitely click the subscribe button
down below and we'll make that video now
let's finally get into the keyboard
comparison we have our magic
keyboard case right here for the ipad
pro so let's
put it on just like that we have this
nice little hinge that i love
and this year with the tab s7 instead of
having a stick on keyboard case like
they did for the tab s6
and other years they actually have a
magnet so should be able to just
put it on just like that that's really
nice because they have this flap
for the s pen so it keeps it nice and
secure
and the real nice benefit with this
keyboard is that it has a detachable
keyboard portion so you literally just
line it up
like this now it's on we have the
keyboard and it actually has a kickstand
in the back and you can adjust
the angle of the kickstand it feels
pretty nice
and on the magic keyboard case for the
ipad pro you have the adjustable
weird floating design which i really
like it's really nice and modern
so with the ipad pro you can't really
detach the keyboard case like you can
with the samsung
but you can just simply lift the ipad
pro and use it with your apple pencil
however you want to and just place it
back that's a nice benefit
and for this you can take off the
keyboard case put it aside
and just watch a movie just like that
now comparing the keys themselves
i really like the magic keyboard keys
that actually feel really good even like
a macbook
or even better than a macbook and going
over to the
tab s7 keyboard wow this
actually does feel really nice
i like the the feedback on this tab s7
keyboard case
but one of the biggest advantages for
the magic keyboard case is that you get
an
extra usb type-c port right here for
power so you can plug it into the wall
and plug in something like a storage
device into the ipad pro itself
now as far as the track pads it seems
like both of these have three finger
swipe gesture support so you can swipe
with three fingers side to side but
unfortunately
it doesn't seem very responsive on the
tab it's a little bit slow
compared to the ipad pro wow look at
that it's so quick
to use these gestures and you could
swipe up for home and it looks like you
can
think you can do the same thing here or
at least go to the app switcher the
samsung does have a
diving board traditional track pad so
it's really difficult to click at the
top but on the magic keyboard case they
went with a new floating design so
no matter where you click you get an
even clicking feel which i'd say is
really really nice and i love that about
the magic keyboard case
another benefit for the magic keyboard
case is that you do get backlit
keys which it seems like you do not get
on the tab s7 keyboard case
now one really nice feature that really
brings this tab s7 alive
is the dax mode dex basically gives you
a more traditional
pc type interface so just like windows
right here you have your apps
as you can see we have a file explorer
right here you can open up google in a
separate window and just
have a nice pc interface one great
decision that samsung made was that they
put the webcam
on the side so when you're web
conferencing or using
zoom it's nice and center compared to
the
ipad pro when you're looking at the
display it actually looks really weird
because the camera is right over here
it definitely has this weird feeling
when you're conferencing with somebody
let's quickly compare the quality of the
webcams and their microphones and you
guys let me know which one is better
down below this is the video and audio
quality of the samsung
galaxy tab s7 this is the video and
audio quality of
the 2020 ipad pro now as far as the
price of these keyboards the magic
keyboard case is 300
compared to 200 for the tab s7 keyboard
case
now the ipad pro does have a couple of
other options
we have the logitech folio touch this
one is a hundred and seventy dollars and
we also have apple's
smart keyboard folio this one is a
hundred and seventy nine dollars so you
do have a couple of other great options
but i'd say that the keyboard on the tab
s7
is definitely better than either of
these budget options for the ipad pro
now before we get into our final
conclusion i do want to mention the
specs and the prices
both of these come with 128 gigs of
storage but the samsung does get a micro
sd card slot
with up to an extra one terabyte of
storage so that's really nice
the samsung is six hundred and fifty
dollars at the base price compared to
eight hundred dollars
for the 11 inch ipad pro but with the
tab s7 you do get the s
pen for free is thrown in there compared
to 130 dollars
extra for the ipad pro now if you get
everything if you get the magic keyboard
case and if you get the keyboard for the
tab s7
it's actually twelve hundred and thirty
dollars
for the ipad pro and eight hundred and
fifty dollars for the tab seven
so you're saving three hundred and
eighty dollars for the full package
and even though the ipad pro has more
performance and has other great features
like the display compared to the tab s7
you really can't beat
the value of this getting the whole
package for 850 dollars
and of course getting the better
speakers as well now if you're a power
user you do get a couple of advantages
with the tab s7
first of all you have an option for 5g
which you can't get on the ipad pro
and you also have that dex which is
really nice for using with the keyboard
and the trackpad
and the benefit is that if you want one
terabyte of storage
you have to pay 500 to get that on the
ipad pro
or you can simply get a one terabyte
microsd card for the tab s7
for around 200 so you save some money
there and the benefit of having a micro
sd card is that next year when you
upgrade again
you can take that out and put it into
your next tablet compared to the ipad
pro where that one terabyte is stuck on
the inside
and if you also deal with video editing
or video footage
you can take out that sd card put it
into your drone for example
record some video then pop it back in
and edit
straight from that card which you can't
do with the ipad pro so with all of that
said
let's finally answer the original
question which one of these tablets is
better in 2020 well i'd say that the tab
s6
definitely has more bang for the buck
you're getting a lot more value
especially if you want the full package
and of course you're now getting
the 120 hertz which is really really
nice and the s pen
finally feels a lot better with the
lowered latency of nine milliseconds
matching the ipad pro now on the other
hand with the ipad pro
you're getting consistent software
updates from apple and they're adding a
lot of features every year
not only that but they hold their value
very very well
compared to other tablets like samsung
tablets on top of that you're getting
the massive ios app store with the ipad
pro
and those apps in those games are
specifically designed
for the ipad pro compared to the google
play store where you do have a lot of
apps and games
but a lot of them are not optimized
specifically for this hardware so
the apps definitely run better on the
ipad pro so based on all of that
we think that if you can't afford to
spend the extra money for the ipad pro
you definitely should because you're
going to be getting a lot more value
in the long term so hopefully you guys
enjoyed this very long and very detailed
comparison video
and if you did tap the like button below
and click the circle above to subscribe
because we're gonna have a gaming
comparison video between these two
going up very soon so thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video